you have some of my favorite tweets yes
I do
every Sunday I do it's my two cents I
just throw out things that come into my
mind
come into your mind listen to this I
have a collection of some of your tweets
here sometimes I wish I were a mailman
yeah I I envy them they walked down and
got the easy route they get off at three
o'clock they drop the bail if you're
going on those upside-down rides count
me out
well there goes my plans for the night
yeah I don't think I've ever eaten a
turnip is that true true you've never
eaten a turnip you eaten eternal yes
I've eaten a turnip yes Cheers
I had I have one before every show this
is this cheers to whoever invented the
q-tip what I do is I sit down on Sunday
nights and I stream out these lists i
don't type them out my wife sends them
out
no reside given to her you just lie
there and you shout
[Laughter]
corncob is a good name for a horse is
this you're just sitting there shouting
no no no Larry again we love you oh good
night you did not come here to be
humiliated
no what I do is so it's a stream of
consciousness I know they're brilliant
we're safe today
you just let let an idea float out I
love this one the rat is perfectly named